what's going on guys
Marvel's blind lawyer Matt Murdock is
hitting the streets for Netflix's
daredevil season two we love the first
season but we want to know what's going
on this season so we brought in a couple
of cool dudes to help us break it down
with please explain daredevil season 2
first off he's an actor and a comedian
you know I'm from here and movie fights
all over the place Mike hashtag Botanica
s' Carlson and he's returning to the
show also an actor comedian a bon vivant
Jason Wayne Christian Before we jump
into the heart of the matter I'd like to
tell you that this episode is brought to
you by Squarespace we're creating a pro
looking website is simple and intuitive
regardless of your skill level my skill
level neophyte if you want to learn more
check out the link in the description
below so gentlemen are you excited about
daredevil season 2 yes uh yeah first off
give me your impressions on season 1
finally something that is absolutely not
for kids yeah this is Marvel
not-safe-for-work
it was dark it was gritty it was violent
not in a way that simply celebrated
those things but in a way that was
appropriate to tell a story of
characters living in this world and
what's nice about daredevil is that you
can have characters spend 20 minutes
talking to each other because that's
stuff we can get in the movie we have to
dig in yeah absolutely
and then we also speaking of digging in
we get to dig out BD seedless characters
and bring them to the forefront
characters like oddball who was a combat
juggler got turned into a really badass
assassin he made a reference to throwing
balls around in a bowling alley yes and
then that's your big tie-in to oh this
was a goofy juggler bad guy in the
comics
that's a deep cut right there nicely
done what are some of your expectations
for season 2
Mike Elektra it seems like they're doing
a different characterization one that's
a little less like kind of Silent
Assassin she seems a little bit more
like kind of I don't know bratty but
it's a great character so my favorite
characters and she's got such a good
storyline in the comics with Matt their
romance the relationship and then
ultimately spoiler alert she dies now we
don't know that that's gonna have a
comment in the comics she dies okay
let me ask you a question so far how
true
has the television show been - the
daredevil comic far more than most
adaptations the only thing that has
struck me spoilers for season 1 as being
off was killing off Ben Ulrich that
characters normally is kind of the POV
character that sticks around throughout
the series uh-huh but it was done even
in a way there that that felt true to
character it was like him not backing
down from an insurmountable threat
I saw Drew Goddard speak about season 1
after the fact and he was saying that
like they wanted to be true to like
these characters in this but this is its
own thing like so a kill up in which
shocked me
I got what no way bench and I love Ben
yeah that like look this is our own
thing so like I expect that like this
thing's gonna veer off even more in
season 2 of like what we expect so
you're talking about Elektra played by
the actress elodi young she was not
introduced last season this is brand new
she actually was okay you fell in love
with that guy degree girl
I can show you you get so we didn't we
didn't see her but we know we know that
she know that she exists so it is that
person what's the relationship in the
comics like between Elektra and
daredevil she lives free of consequence
and completely in the moment and is a
character that is obsessed with the now
and then Matt dealing with the kind of
the Catholic guilt is very much a person
about consequence and what the stakes
are
everybody is excited about the Punisher
okay Frank Castle one of my favorite
comic book characters of all time he's
not had a truly great filmed incarnation
yet what do we think about this choice
of Jon Bernthal as the Punisher and what
do we think his role is going to be this
season Mike Jon Bernthal looks cool yeah
I feel like he's gonna swagger to him
that we kind of want as far as his role
in this season I'm assuming he's gonna
be a foil to daredevil he has a
different way to do things he's a guy
that likes to kill people rudl he
doesn't have any sort of moral code
about it it looked like whenever they
were setting up the first trailers and
promotional images for season two then
yeah Punisher was going to kind of fill
the role of kingpin in terms of main
antagonists not necessarily villain but
this is who he's going up against uh-huh
the last trail
that just released kind of show that
that was all a red herring and it's
going to be the hand it looks like the
Punisher is more going to be this third
party wreaking havoc on both sides are
we setting up the Punisher for his own
show we have to be there's no way
there's no way they don't want that in
the comics
what is Daredevil and the Punishers
relationship there is a great comic
where Punisher actually captures
daredevil chains him up to a chimney on
a rooftop gives him a gun and he says
kill me right now or I'm gonna kill this
criminal to show him that Punishers
black-and-white world view the only way
to stop crime is the final way is death
so the relationship is great yeah a good
friend good thank you fast rely but it
seems like there are two sides of the
same coin I was an ideological battle
between the two of them it's just like
Carole and Morgan you know Walking Dead
talk to me about your thoughts on the
hand from the comics I'm gonna make a
hilarious joke the hand we have a hand
and a lot of different characters I see
what you did there
so they've like sort of just been this
kind of presence that are in the shadows
a lot of time with Marvel they've had
fights a Wolverine they've been fights
with daredevil if I invited so many
people were they in service to the Beast
which is technically this weird demon
was it an ancient Japanese tin goo
spirit or just the controlling five
members of the hand their original
founder back in the 1500s was named kaki
Nobu which no small coincidence the
ninja leader that we saw last season's
name was Nobu so we think that was a
reference to to that original founder so
they can be hired you can hire the hand
to do your evil bidding if you want do
you think we're gonna see kingpin again
because he's in the comics he's been a
classic foe of the Punisher yeah we have
to see him at at some point and let her
last we left him he was being
incarcerated if we see the hand go up
against the other ninja order which is
called the chase led by the Daredevils
blind teacher stick I think we're not
even seen kingpin until the final
episode where all of a sudden he sweeps
up what's left of the hand and takes
over gotcha
and so you mentioned stick Scott Glenn
one of the great supporting characters
from last season
what do we expect from stick this season
leading the chase we're definitely going
to see Stone who we saw his scarred
back in last season we might see shaft
and some of the other mono named not
shaft the 70s blacksploitation detect
although that would be great that'd be
fantastic we heard a female voice in the
trailer as well that I may be wrong but
I think was still Madame Gao from season
one if she's in then we might get some
teases towards Iron Fist we might get a
steel serpent reference are there any
arcs or any storylines that you're
expecting from the season that we
haven't talked about or just an overall
direction you know any of the different
Electra storylines and probably she's
probably not going to die they're
probably not gonna just do what we think
they're gonna do but like will see
bull's eye yeah I feel like we would see
him ready if he was gonna be a big part
of the season so I feel like if we see
me only gonna be like a little bit of a
tease save him for season three are they
gonna start tying in characters like
Jessica Jones and Luke Cage and bring
them together like how soon is that
gonna start happening now we pretty much
know like what the defenders looks like
neither there's no way we're not going
to get at least little teases if not
maybe full-out cameos we don't know
let's jump ahead what did the defenders
look like in the comic book universe I
don't know that we've had this specific
lineup of the defenders in the comics is
it wrongheaded of me to think of the
defenders as more of like a street-level
Avengers I think that's what they're
playing at here yeah I don't think it's
going in around I'm familiar with but at
the same time they've been doing so good
I'll wait to see the product before I
render judgment sure outside of
defenders did Daredevil and Jessica
Jones cross paths to daredevil in Luke
Cage cross paths daredevil seems up with
almost every solo person he's teamed up
with Wolverine he's teamed up with Ghost
Rider he's teamed up with Punisher of
course teamed up with Elektra he's
actually had a long romance with Black
Widow okay so I mean daredevil gets
around as a partner yeah sounds like it
anything else you're looking forward to
probably the ninja version of that raid
style hallway fight uh-huh something to
top that episode - yeah that we all like
blew us all that was epic and they
showed a guy getting like exhaustedly
tired which is great about it like he's
just by the end he's really like okay
yeah I'm looking forward to that I'm
looking forward to ninja battles and
looking forward to the Punisher Elektra
the hand uh it sounds like it's gonna be
a pretty great season I'm gonna be
watching it all within the first weekend
yes are you going to binge daredevil
season two
let us know in the comments below who
are you looking forward to seeing most
tell us and the best answer we're going
to send you a screen junkies t-shirt I
want to thank Mike
hashtag Botanica Carlson Jason Wayne
Christian you gentlemen are a treasure
trove of knowledge and I thank you for
being here I want to thank you for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye-bye
thanks again to Squarespace for making
this episode possible start your free
trial site today at WWC where space comm
slash screen junkies show or just click
the Squarespace logo on the screen when
you decide to sign up for Squarespace
make sure that you use the offer code
screen junkie show to get 10% off your
first purchase Squarespace build it
beautiful